all right Jamal yeah born and raised
hello to the couch yeah
48 and actual years but 27 because
prison you don't age yeah because if I
go back I'm gonna go back to a
maximum-security not better be ready
it's like I remember it was yesterday no
I was um the oldest boy of five my
mother you know saying she was a good
mother you know I'm sacred I was the
only boy at one time I can get away with
anything I say anything anything so I
kept my mother in a lot of trouble my
mother she would she'd be fine for me
because I was the only boy but one time
I got beat up and came to the house
crying she told me don't you ever come
in the house crying from getting beat up
and she told me if you can't beat them
up pick up something and knock the [ __ ]
it's been effective for 48 years and
twins so real I'm very dangerous and I'm
gonna get to that in a minute but at the
age of nine something terribly happened
to me I didn't know how that this is
we're gonna come when it's gonna happen
and it still affects me today morning be
it back then we've thrown our way to
Louisiana my mama and my sister when we
got to Louisiana but before we got to
Louisiana my mother if she was teaching
us how to going the ladies in front of
us person when I mean have no money so
you steal ya ain't mad that I forgot
done same because I don't know how we
got to that part but I knew it was
something because my family her siblings
were scared are they it's a mystery
nobody want to talk
about my mother her own sisters and
brothers still today but I heard a story
but I can't believe what they say so we
stopped at one Greyhound bus station
I seen the village the first vending
machine with all this stuff in it you
didn't have that little door that flaps
up and maybe a little I can reach my
hand in it and shaking like I'm having a
seizure and that's hot pants
you know said yeah I got the name my
nickname is Papa because I watched all
the people do stuff you know saying well
whatever they do I'm watching them that
you know said to me I still remember so
we get there but once we get to
Louisiana where her auntie my mama up to
stay it's like by 1:00 2:00 in the
morning
she wouldn't let her same time machine
you have no clothes I didn't make them
since we just came all the way to
California no we don't have no money she
tell him I'll come back tomorrow gonna
go never been home said that time he
phone so the cab drivers like okay
Jonathan staying with me for that I take
y'all in the morning mama agreed to it
but we did have no other choice I was
tired because I get a check today
because they said something I'm hike for
whatever whatever it is you know I'm sad
but I've been getting that since the kid
anyway
so when we do to cabdriver I actually go
to sleep
I was a little guys for the bed seemed
like I had to climb off the bed to get
off up sure somebody is disturbing my
sleep it's my sister now this is my
older sister I love her smile
because we witness what I'm gonna tell
y'all it's again so she wakes me up and
told me to come with her he goes in a
room the cab driver is trying to have
sex with my mother yes I know what's
going on I was I was sharp I was shocked
because you know I'm saying I pick up
everything where it might even in I said
I've kissed a busted foggers over to
order whatever I trying to learn
something new every day no matter what
did he try to me because my entellus
'been oasis a terrible thing to waste in
mind to me so I'm looking around the god
cab driver he has like three shotguns in
the corner I'll pick up one of [ __ ] it
right you know I'm nice for the back pad
and stuff around okay are you showing us
in cockpit the poor chick but he knew
what was going on they were sick tied
him up I don't know all the stuff that I
know I don't know where I learned this
stuff some other stuff from you don't
saying I know some more stuff from her
or not - yeah Casey still be open so
anyway we leave no Shannon I remember us
because I fell asleep again we went to a
hotel a motel you know and we've never
seen rear dancing they don't have no
sidewalk you know it was different to me
so we stayed there for a few days we ran
out of money so now it's a big old
trailer trucks selling fruits up the
side we lift up the back me and my
sister who take cases you know all type
of food and today I love all type of
foods I love so we eventually goes to my
great grandmother house where she has
money you come out there to get some
money she got she she's well she's well
off you know said that's all these
people go out in all type of stuff
so I remember us we do bad so I knew we
had some money and I'm Akay I'm just
program
so we go back my mother's we're outside
and she's reading the Bible I remember
grandmother Turner bring the kids inside
what's outside you know I'm saying I go
to sleep again
I wake up my sister jumping on the
screaming you know I see my mom and
she's like right there no hey yeah I
don't know what's going right no no
before she's laid out and see my uncle
hitter but it was my I was just too
drowsy cuz I was a little psyche minutes
back then whatever she drives me so I
woke up begin and so remember my sister
say my mama's paying my mother I've seen
him hitting there with the defibrillator
I know I know but this was a woman I was
like what's going on then they took us
outside and whatnot my mother's dead at
the age of nine they didn't have
children services like they have today
back then nobody came in and check up on
me thank you all thank you because
the sad and I can't stand nobody
disrespect mom because whatever that I
can't even put a feeling to it but my
cousin silly when his mother passed he
said you've been feeling this way all
that time killing get one mom
so anyway
next twenty thirty some years I'm
incarcerated was our criminal no I just
have taken care of myself
I like to fight you know a very violent
mama raised me man
not only now in 2016
he's getting my check y'all didn't
smother with you but now they saying I
have PTSD I always thought that was
something for a soldier or whatnot
whatnot
Wow you know where as I look at my sim I
was forced to get therapy because of the
system because the law don't like the
ball because shorts my mother is
definitely because the police the
sheriff chill my hook in the county
chief his elbow connected to the thigh
bone yeah mine is like that you know
yeah of them doing action you know every
day any killed they killed me but they
killed me but it's a lot of Secrets of
my family that I don't they they don't
want to but it has something to do with
my uncle dying you don't see him killing
it my grandmother told me told her
daughter
don't call the ambulance I ain't never
told nobody this but she assisted her
daughter Timmy Timmy because the
landlord stayed up front and I got a
little longer I'm gonna put it out there
ain't got nothing to hide
one of her siblings told me and I
believe it that she went over to our
house and she seen my grandmother's
boyfriend coming out my mama's room
that makes a lot of sense but my mother
was very promiscuous because she had to
take care of them kids her man is locked
away I used to go there for family
visits and I thought that was my
playground everything until I really
went there after their don't ya
so anyway like I said I'm very fired
because prison because I'm a gang member
of West Side bps it was my family stone
love is my family they took care I'd
have to go through training or I was
already ready so as I looked at my
siblings nowadays my mom I had a special
batch of kids subscribe here my sister
hitting me in the head a team statement
and a cover for four days not knowing
I'm being charged with GTA because I
left work and went away so much for
waste management I left work to talk to
her about the problem that I had and
I don't know wonderful things you or the
whatever whatever but I see stars green
clovers blue diamonds and purple lights
camera action you oh man they came to
explain that but in the process now here
on how understand why I'm here but you
know they should know makes it and all I
hear is that we all here to e sound
sometimes says the gum I hear that 24
hours a day
yeah nurse talking me you up saying you
used to be loud yeah it's gonna go away
that's being almost you know now I have
a problem with people thinking like norm
people I can't hear like him if I
dropped my phone right there I'm gonna I
can't hear and it's frustrating trying
to deal with that with my mental illness
in the substance that I put in my body
it's not working from I know that
because I felt like game from baked add
me on written and everything's a lot of
stuff that I did stab my sister in the
Irish screwdriver cut her throat and not
one I'm teeth out but I don't remember
none of that but I see the scar they're
up by six
I don't remember none of that but now
that I think about it I know why it's
called black
my sister stayed behind hospital when
she did this she came the next day to
see me
wondering how or who will pay for the
window because I was banging on the
window at night she's excited about this
but more to me in my mind so as she
explained and starts to apologize I
forgave her because nobody knew about
the blackout when she spoke but she
blacked out I couldn't hold her
something smart for something I'm
nobody should get as angry as I get I
can go from zero to 60 and 0.0 second
Japan the military can't disappoint me
I play weapons for my show prison hey
here's your sense taught how to make 9
because prison it ain't for they help
you it's finally gonna corrupt you they
don't debrief us when they let us go I
didn't seem so much like a big from keel
to Pelican Bay in Crescent City when I
hid there that's his nose in there mm
look up tomorrow ends how I'm ready for
this I was but this is it this is hey
hey this is the live show her mother
loved her for money and invited
Washington dono
yeah because they ain't no fighter
stabbing and yeah they put all the wolf
California has to offer in one place
Crescent City where rain eight months
ago I think that I like to stab people
Heinlein look at my record my mama
played with knives
later on she won't get Montague tonight
that's why her it's nothing personal
I had to stab my son two years ago
because I had never been disrespected
that much fighting nobody people said
why didn't you fight heat and deserve a
fight because it is what it is I tried
diplomacy when diplomacy failed
I mean they say I'm crazy Goodell oh
this is her mama had special best kick
like daughter she's just like me
I've been going hungry she had my an
attitude she already got two strikes and
she ain't even 22 and she was born
that's why you see these two names with
the leaps on all the days in the world
why my mother birthday yeah hmm
it's a lot of stuff that I just don't
understand but maybe ain't up to me
understand cuz when I was a kid I was
told that white down at that point with
the blue eyes
that was James's right okay
because they just talked that they
thought that they thought that they just
thought that but when I started doing
time in prison I called it the heating
university because you're learning a lot
a lot my sister one day she's I wanted
this go stop you been out here
I do the time the time don't you do me I
don't count the years and I'm doing it
he is gone I come from a very very good
family
how will you start there before they
started passing away I love you auntie
vaunette
because she kept us together and my
sisters in him know that there wasn't no
I don't get along with you every
Saturday me doing something not just
because of my mother's death but she had
like that and she was about to him every
year my mom would take the whole and
everybody that she had like this you
know she was up well but you know when
she got they didn't tell me I was across
lady when she that hit him tell
[Music]
Lemmy is a waffle that was prison like
Juno hardware as junior prison are four
stages to go through the [ __ ] these
people go through boys hold four songs
but I went from boys home Y which is
junior prison where you really learn how
to fight as soon as you come through the
door where you from I'm from minute [ __ ]
this
and y'all fight so as they didn't up
being the minority because for everyone
blood it's probably 20 Crips we held our
[ __ ]
it's hard to be a blood we paved the way
for y'all man but a lot of you blessed
just saved my shame drugs and I can tell
cuz I'm gonna look it on the back of
your neck and I know he's gonna say it's
gonna say mate in China but I end up
going to juvenile hall I was doing
fighting man but I was in foster home
mom she's unstable a lot of time a lot
of time she's running from his stuff I
can't answer but stuff me my sister
remember her got only would have stayed
there whenever because for my win the
people try to keep me but I don't know
how to know how I work being and whatnot
when my mama finally got his back and I
just thought about that did she get us
back to take her life because it was a
lot going on my momma was depressing
omentum and I look at all my siblings
all got issues and I can diagnose them
they don't bless fake isn't there
because because then I was molested at
the age of pie issue
yeah I left round around the top because
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
let me who's already had issues man
don't know but you could have changed my
sexuality lucky I'm a lesbian only miss
removing my fears father sick son of a
[ __ ]
I believe my auntie allowed it to happen
every time I believe her son believe
because this [ __ ] [ __ ] had to
eleventeen you know sucking the dicks at
the same time he had too much time but
that's without they had the cocaine that
was called upon Rhea flake my earth
Union probably was high off the plate
because it's like no Jesus it's
something about kids sleep when you
gotta go as Claire be the best sleep in
the world
hey time for me to get up I gotta piss
Crowley that knows him slider Solomon
oh yeah
his son told me my dad said yeah let
your dick ride to the left
he suckered his mother said he's buying
a shoe stuff the shopping we all said
nothing he was doing back but fifty on
eleven-year-old kid
he's always screws I would think I can
say I was special but I was specially
cuz I was a class with oh that's the
only thing you should have never did was
[ __ ] me cuz now y'all turn me into a boy
whoever he is I'm coming for that [ __ ]
[ __ ] and whoop your ass that's nice
girlfriend
and I'm sorry for the motive that your
daughter's name is I was [ __ ] they
wear to because I knew more than they
knew
you could have chained my sexuality and
I think it affected because I already
cared about oil for all set as you can
see I got a tattoo of a more give them a
[ __ ] but I love even [ __ ] and I write
the inner gotta put on them and that
points to you know girly
cuz I think it'll be a force I'm gonna
comedian too sir but this story that I
was seeing this true
Ferg n I ran into a girl oh yeah God
hold on let me give you some hair the
more time you can see me there boy but
and I'm the king of the baby backs that
means a lot of times I ain't puttin no
sock on the paper I am so passionate for
real
but my sexual demons you know they call
it tricky I called it painful what I
won't because now I believe a wing
steady course a [ __ ] and make money so
I'm selling this big bottle Pam I can't
do it that way if I stand on the cup you
gonna be gay and that's the price we
have to see it all work for gay person
everybody your stereotype nearly all of
us that work these come on except
thought you were gay woman Josh was just
last week Russia I ain't giving a [ __ ]
and I said that if she cared I said she
cared if I'd be a porn star because I
love it I bingo I either they recommend
that I go to a sexual sex sex class sex
addiction now older women there that
lives today story I got no phone book
listed gotta go back though because I
enjoy and I have to pay for but
I want to be happy I entirely live the
American dream you remember that name I
dream I just want to be happy because I
have so much hurt and pain you know
that's why I get so emotional and what
people get it [ __ ] them you see tears
out these eyes that don't mean I'm a
softie
that means you better run and I am you
know dang go kill me I'm a survivor and
i work 4-9 snakes for me
anyway
no problem thank you for listening